a lot of passion
you know what that was perfect hi it's
alex and you guys know me i love a good
challenge my name is
surprise surprise i don't speak farsi
but today i'm gonna try to learn alex
does have two lifelines she can phone a
friend once and she can use google
translate once maybe you should give me
like a little crash course in farsi
right now i do know how to count to four
yek
yeah how about five who do you think i
am i don't think i'm like the perfect
authority i was born here but i can at
least say most words how about you give
me three key words right now
which means more bish chart i know nah i
know no and yes is otta and yes is arai
if you ever get really frustrated just
say like zoyaje di josh
[Music]
maybe we need a pan
yeah yeah all right yes big small
pig
zorge i like that it's like bazooka or
something we got the big guns today
let's heat this up high medium low
actually i would just say medium and
farsi maybe a little oil in the pan okay
yeah i have had a lot of persian food
since knowing zoya here
a little just a little
yes
okay so i'm gonna put a tablespoon yes
yek tablespoon i'm assuming we're gonna
do more chicken okay yes i have a spidey
sense in languages
makes total sense i'm going to let this
melt down get a little hot before i put
the chicken in okay then we're going to
fry the chicken
more more
is pepper we gotta season the chicken
this is persian food we don't just do
salt and pepper okay cumin
yeah
yeah one tablespoon
one teaspoon
wait wait wait wait hobe is remember
like when i'm on the phone and i say
hobie he's like that's good oh that's
good
and this turmeric okay you love your
tumeric so we got our seasoned chicken
now i mix this up okay
i'm gonna get this all nice and coated
no okay now
got it look at me go guys i don't even
need these lifelines when something's
like
ba ba ba is literally like like like
fantastic like it's like like almost
like if you like smell something it's
like like yeah
i can say that one i like
it
any more seasonings yeah sugar yeah you
do have two lifelines i don't know if
you want to use it this early i know i'm
a little concerned to use it this early
pias
flip it
no not yet
yet
i know ness you told
so
yeah look at that color on that chicken
so now you would
[Applause]
are you impressed with me so far i'm
always impressed with you
i don't know what you just said i'm just
kidding
so i'm gonna shred this chicken
so you grew up obviously eating a lot of
persian food my mom's a phenomenal cook
my parents moved from iran when they
were in their 20s
after the revolution so i was born here
and then i got to basically experience
growing up as a first generation
persian iranian in orange county asan
oh alex i'm assuming i put this chicken
back in here
no we're going to make rice or something
no pan a smaller pan
the
melt it down
all right this is melted and i don't
know what i'm doing so i'm gonna take it
off the heat before it burns listen to
this okay
oh i said i'm listening
paste that's the taste like a peanut
saffron pistachios yes
okay so i'm toasting nuts in butter
yeah
the berries the berries
what is a barberry it's like a little
tiny even like tinier than a current are
they sour
they're swedish sour so the thing is you
should wash them first
good to know so we washed them
next
how many of these yick
one tablespoon yeah
one one cup
rinse them off
in the butter
one minute yeah oh wow toss them in the
butter
cook them a little bit for one minute is
that chica
sugar yes yes chicago
one
much cleaner
i feel like whenever you're learning a
language there's some key phrases you
need to know like a greeting
maybe where's the bathroom also like
cheers is always a good one to know i
know some so whenever you pick up the
phone and you're speaking to your
parents you say
salam hobby salam
salam hobe is a quick hello are you good
like how are you basically where's the
bathroom dash frequency destruction you
never know when you need to go you never
know when you just by yourself might be
lost in iran salamatti it's cheers yeah
we actually use that one quite a bit
whenever we're drinking wine
in the pistachio
wow that's funny
a little lesson helped me before this
half of this in here
oh this is good
yes
there's two more
i feel like persian food at least what
you've made for me always serves on the
side of more like sour
yeah we don't have too many spicy foods
actually you use a lot of spices but
it's not like hot spicy the more yik
a goal would be something that's very
beautiful rose yes
one tablespoon in here
yeah it's pretty fragrant yeah
listen when you cook persian food or
whatever you never use recipes you
always feel with your heart yeah that's
what i like to do too yeah otherwise
side yeah
i'm assuming we're going to do rice now
yeah
let's measure this one out because
sometimes feeling with your heart only
gets you so far always gotta rinse your
rice
well while we wait for this water to
boil why don't you teach me six through
ten sheesh
like shish kebab i do they have six
pieces it's just it's like six indents
kind of
that's not
half and hashed
half
[Music]
something like really endearing for me
to say to you would be like
which just means like you're so sweet
we're boiling okay how do they banish
the berries still up now put it in okay
stir it a little bit yeah i just felt it
yeah thank god you just taught me that
10 minutes okay
[Music]
saffron yeah
so from the bible's room to
so i know that
is water
and i know that you gotta bloom the
saffron in the water so that's what
we're gonna do so i'm gonna put like a
little how much this also yeah
yeah one tablespoon okay like that
that's good
we're gonna do a little this crunchy
crunch see this i know because i've
watched you
use saffron a lot water
how much like just a little
saffron like never comes out we're good
i didn't spill no no no
you can't just make up words
hollyda
yeah water strain this off and cut the
temp so it stops cooking huh all right
we've got the parboiled rice hello
do you remember what mora was chicken so
turkmen more
eggs yes
whisk the tortilla crack them
okay
maybe i should have used the lifeline
now i think you're going to use life
really now okay here we go i'm using
zoya's friend nicolette
okay let's call nicolette hello
hi nicola
how are you i'm okay kind of struggling
let's try okay i'm going to put you on
music for a second zardi zardi
okay
zardi
it's a good it literally translates to
ball of chicken a bottle of chicken wait
that's amazing but what is zardi
zara dear so it's the yellow part so the
yolk oh yeah it's the yellow part oh so
i only use the yolk oh okay so yolk of
the egg that was great thank you so much
that really helped excite to see what
you make yes thank you nicolette see you
later you're welcome
i forgot what bai was
office
yeah okay we need the yolk of the egg
i'm gonna wash my hands real quick let's
go for it i guess that would have helped
knowing that before i cracked them wow
phone a friend was very helpful good job
nicolette
zade tofu
saffron in here
wait the eggs in the saffron uh-huh
there's some two eggs in here
saffron here
but rice or mix this up first example
wait wait
most
[Music]
why would i know that like is there
something i've used before we used it
earlier oil
how much oil
what did you do i said you're doing so
well so far yeah i think that's what i
heard i think that you're going to learn
by tomorrow
before everything is
for leave on
this foot
tablespoon
leave on half a cup
now we whisk
rice yeah into here okay rice in
oh
here
i think it's a good time to teach you
another word um another phrase it's
ganzadi
ganza yeah it means you made a mess
that is the story of my life the word of
my life
so just a little
rub it around okay there we go
doing like a little rice pie
i might make it to the end without using
my last lifeline guys
chicken okay
wow
this is a complicated recipe guys okay
papa bubba nah bubba baba is another
thing we say it's just kind of like no
dude but bubba means dad holla behind
your base
might as well go live in iran i think
you should you'd be very popular i'm too
loud for any other country persians
literally screamed oh wow i belong there
yeah
miserable to your oven oven
i said oven so i hope that you got that
one yeah
put in a aluminium
on a pan
aluminium aluminium pan put it in
aluminium what's aluminium oven foil
oh my god my brain is at enough and then
available
charsatur
[Music]
that was tough i felt like i'm in math
class over here all right now we bake
good luck
okay
let's see what you did first and then
we'll see if we're gonna cheers i did
something
i have a feeling i know what we're doing
it is time to flip
[Music]
that means i have so much faith in you
you're gonna do well oh good yeah i do
too so i'm just gonna flip it like you
do you flip it with confidence you flip
it with ease yeah why don't you give it
a countdown say
don't we actually go the other way we
don't say three two one we go one two
three all right
look at how perfectly it popped out oh
my god am i persian you know they have
the superstition at least with tadiq
that if your tadiq flips in is crispy
you're ready for marriage is it the same
with touching
wow that looks pretty good
it's very expressive
yeah
it's wrong hello
just like a little decoration
it's going to be rustic
can i just do my own design absolutely
not yeah
okay
oh good guys
look at what i've done
honestly this is like the best thing
i've ever made i did it with farsi
instructions i do have my own version
though so maybe we can kind of compare
oh
whoa
okay i get the uh kind of less
shrimp that makes more sense to me now i
can see that you have a really nice
golden crispy crust you're more ready
for marriage than i am
i think i did a really good job
considering this was a very very complex
involved recipe i think it looks
incredible but we do have to check the
inside too we have to see
how the layering stood up and the most
ideal would be a very crispy outer layer
then the inside should be fluffy and
moist we're going to cut into similarly
to how you cut a cake
looks pretty good it's staying like
pretty well together and now
we'll cut yours nice
initial thoughts it looks like my
chicken is like a bit chunkier maybe i
didn't shred it as well
it also looks like you have like
definitely a better crisp all the way
around but they look very similar all
right let's see if they taste equally
delicious is there anything you say when
you eat anusha john
mr john okay let's try yours first
it tastes fantastic it's really good you
did a really good job tana tan and farsi
right yeah that's good enough now should
we try yours i think we should mine them
okay
i think comparing them they're they're
honestly very very similar i did
job and i think i am persian at heart
tachine is definitely a dish worth
making it was so delicious but until
next time hold office
oh yes
[Music]
you